- [Mark] All right, J.J.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] J.J., where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- [J.J.] I grew up in
Los Angeles, California.
- [Mark] And tell me about your family,
you had both your parents
when you were a kid?
- [J.J.] Well no, my family was divorced,
divorced by the time I was five-years-old.
- [Mark] You were raised by your mom?
- Well, I was raised by my
father and my grandmother.
- [Mark] And where was mom?
- Well, my mother stayed
in Compton, California,
and they kinda like took me
from her when I was of age,
of born, like maybe two-years-old.
My grandmother took me from my mother,
because she felt I was my
father's kid after a while.
So they took me, and then my
father and mother divorced.
- [Mark] How would you
describe your childhood?
- Well, I didn't really
understand my childhood.
I didn't get to play a lot as a kid.
My father kept me with him,
always riding around in the car with him.
And I just didn't have a lot
of friends at an early age,
and from there
my sister was my grandmother's favorite.
And so what happened there
is after a while, my mother,
when I turned about eight,
my mother wanted us back.
So she went to court, and she got us back.
And my grandmother just developed
some real messed up feelings towards me,
because she felt it was my fault
for asking her, constantly asking her,
"Where was my mother at?"
And so my mother got us back.
And from there,
my mother started having problems
with alcohol and drinking.
So my father found another
reason to get us back.
And once he got us back,
my grandmother just had
this type of hatred for me.
And she would just at a
early age, make me sweep,
clean the house.
She gave my sister everything,
and didn't give me too
much of anything as a kid.
And from there, my
grandfather used to take me
in the back house.
We had a back house also
with the front house, and
my grandfather used to molest me as a kid,
and make me
just have oral sex with him as a kid,
which I knew nothing about at that time.
- [Mark] How old were you?
- I was about seven and eight
when he used to do this.
And I think once my
auntie came to the door,
and she saw it, and she didn't
even say anything about it.
She just kept doing what she was doing.
So this kinda messed my
head up, coming up as a kid.
I kinda thought that maybe
this was a part of life.
I didn't know any better than that.
And so, as I grew up and got older,
I just didn't know
which way to go in life.
And I ended up at a very
early age here on Skid Row,
and I was here for wow, maybe 23,
to age of 23 to now,
being very indecisive on what life was.
I always felt like I was alone,
and nobody really cared.
My family didn't.
I remember once when I
went to stay with my mother
at probably about 18 or 19,
and try to give it another go.
My stepfather at that
time, she was remarried.
He didn't too much like me,
so I ended up after going to work,
I used to have to sleep in the cupboard
in the car shed, in the
garage, in the parking stall.
We had some apartments,
and there was a parking stall
over the top of the garage.
And I used to have to go
sleep inside the garage,
the parking stall.
And it's like, I can hear
my mother going to work
in the morning, and start her car up.
And she wouldn't even know
that I'm literally in the parking stall,
right above the car, going to sleep.
And just had a horrible life growing up,
having to go through all this stuff.
I felt like nobody really cared,
and I didn't know which way to go in life.
And once I hit skid row,
it was just so much of the
same type of stuff down here.
A lot of people that was damaged,
a lot of people that had mental
problems, or drug problems.
And it's kinda like I felt
that I was amongst people
like myself, and I had
the same type of problems
these people did.
And it just turned into
pretty much all of my life.
You know, being my age now,
I've been down here 38 years,
and I never just had too much to go on.
Never really nobody to
guide me, nobody to tell me
that it was gonna be okay,
that it wasn't my fault,
the things that happened to me as a kid.
I was constantly beaten by
my grandmother, and my uncle,
coming up for no reason at all.
You know, something wasn't did right,
or I said the wrong thing.
So I constantly was always
getting beat and whooped
by the family, and my life's just been
a horror story, if you ask me.
Just growing up, stuff,
I don't think a kid
should have to go through,
and I constantly a battle
with this, to the date.
I constantly have to try to figure out,
am I worth it?
Or why did I have to go through
this type of stuff as a kid?
And my life is a little better now,
because I'm older,
and I'm able to put a
lot of stuff behind me,
and I try harder.
But things just keep coming
into play that have to do
with my childhood and all that.
- [Mark] Intellectually,
you can understand
that this is not your fault.
- Yes.
- [Mark] But that doesn't really help you,
'cause your subconscious, your behavior.
- No, it doesn't help me because
it's all I knew growing up.
You gotta figure as a kid, when it starts
at such an early age
and you're being beat,
you're being molested, you're
going through all this stuff,
and nobody says anything about it.
You kinda start believing it's your fault.
- [Mark] Did you ever feel
like anyone loved you?
- No, I didn't feel like
I was loved as a kid.
I felt like I was told
what to do all my life,
and how to do it, and if
it wasn't did that way,
then I was gonna be in
trouble for some reason.
That's how it usually ended up.
When I grew up and learned
that what my grandfather
was doing, wasn't right.
That even had more of a play on my mind,
because now I had bottled
all this stuff inside of me,
and I was afraid to let anyone know.
My mother passed, not even knowing this.
I never told her at all
that I was constantly molested as a kid.
She never even knew it,
and she passed going to
her grave not even knowing
what my grandfather on my father's side
had constantly done to me.
I just felt so ashamed of it,
or I didn't know how to explain it to her.
So I just kept that a
secret all of my life.
This is probably only
the second or third time
in my life that I've even
mentioned that to anybody.
What had happened to me as a kid
is just something I kept
as a secret inside of me.
- [Mark] How has that affected
your life as an adult?
- It's affected me a great deal.
- [Mark] I'm certain it has,
but I'm wondering like--
- Well, I feel unworthy.
I feel unworthy of anything.
I feel that mentally people can look at me
and know that I have been through stuff.
I'm hurt, I'm ashamed,
and there was never nobody
to talk to about it.
- [Mark] Have you had
romantic relationships?
- Yes, I have had romantic relationships.
- [Mark] With women or men?
- With women mostly.
Other things with men I would try,
because I didn't know if this was me.
- [Mark] Right, you get confused by the.
- Yeah, I was confused.
So I didn't know what
was going on in my life,
so I just felt the right
way was with women.
But I just didn't know what
I was gonna do in my life.
So I've always been confused
sexually in that part,
because of my lifestyle,
and I grew up like that,
and I grew up not being
understood by women,
because they never knew my background,
and they never knew
what was wrong with me,
why I would go through certain things.
So my life has just been
a complete disaster,
is the best I can put it.
You know, it's just been
a disaster from day one,
and to the point that some times I wonder
if I was cursed or something.
Maybe there's a curse over me,
or my whole family or something.
And I just didn't know,
and there's nothing I can do about it.
And that's the bad part about it,
feeling that you going
through all this in life,
and not feeling there's
nothing you can do about it.
You know, there's no heeling to it,
because it's just the way life is.
- [Mark] Are you living on the street?
- Yes, I'm on the streets now.
I've been on the streets.
Every now and then I'll
try to make a break,
and do something positive,
but I think because of
what I go through mentally,
I always run back to this,
because I don't know how
to really deal with people
and what's expected of me.
So I just come back to the streets,
where I feel a part of it.
- [Mark] Yeah, are
drugs part of your life?
- [J.J.] Drugs is part of my life also.
I think I started using
drugs to self-medicate,
and to try to block the
memories of what I go through.
And a lot of times they
would help, not knowing
that what they were doing
was actually putting me
in more to the whole lifestyle,
and becoming an addict
because of the drug scene.
And I think that entrapped
me even more into Skid Row,
not being aware, or
practicing right and wrong,
or what's good and bad.
This whole thing down here
has became a lifestyle to me.
- [Mark] And you have all these emotions
that must come up from this.
- [J.J.] Yeah, I've never knew
how to deal with emotions.
I messed up so many relationships
because of the emotions.
- [Mark] What do you deal with most?
Is it anger, or depression, or anything?
- [J.J.] Depression, I
believe it's depression
and anxiety, is what I deal with most.
And I've never been
treated for either one,
so I don't know how to handle 'em,
and sometimes I'd sleep for days.
Like now, I just got up
after a two day sleep.
It's like, I don't even
want to open my eyes
and look at what I'm going
through in life, you know.
So I just try to sleep it away,
until I just have to get up, and go eat,
and take care of myself.
- [Mark] What was the
worst point in your life?
- The worst part of my life was,
I believe have to.
I had a daughter,
and because of all the
confusion in my head,
I didn't know how to
even be a father to her.
I didn't know how to say,
"Well, I went through this,
so I'm gonna make sure
she had a better life."
So my life just turned out
where it was affecting
a young child's life,
just like mines was affected,
and where she had to go
stay with other people too.
I just didn't know what
she had went through
in her life, if it was similar to mine.
So it was, I can say that was
the worst part of my life,
having a child and not trying
to do better by that child,
and not knowing if her life
was just as messed up as mine.
- [Mark] What's your view on life?
Is it just, people are evil,
and it's a dog-eat-dog, and
just every man for himself?
I mean, do you feel
betrayed by your family?
- I think it's a little bit of all of it.
I think if it would've
been more interest taken
into me as a child,
then maybe I would have
understood some things?
- [Mark] It's easy for you to have
a very negative view on existence.
- Right, yes, exactly.
- [Mark] With what you went through.
- I would have been able to
see things more positive,
and separate some of
the things and saying,
okay, that happened, and it
was a bad thing that happened,
but just told to move on,
that I'm a good person, or something.
I've never had that
positive input, really,
a lot of times.
So my view of life is that,
it was just a bad place.
People were all bad.
Nobody really understood or
cared about the next person.
It was all about what
they can get out of life.
And I was just a pawn in it,
and people were selfish.
They didn't really care
about me or anybody else.
- [Mark] What's the most important lesson
you've learned in your life?
- The most important
lesson I learned in life,
is not to give up.
Like I said, even though
I've been down here
all these years, even though
I went through everything
I went through in life,
I think the most in
person lesson I learned,
is not to give up on it.
That it is my life, and it's
mine to make the best of.
So each day I get up, I
stand and I still think
that something's gonna happen for me.
Something good is gonna happen,
and all this would turn around.
And I think I'll just
continue to think that,
and believed that until the day I go.
- [Mark] You still have hope.
- I still have hope.
- [Mark] That's excellent,
that's great to hear.
- I have to hope that--
- [Mark] You should.
- Thank you.
- [Mark] Do you ever have urges to do
what was done to you with children?
That's a common story.
- Not to a child, not to a child.
I think because it was
done to me as a child.
I think it's the wrong
thing to do to a child.
I think when I was younger,
I didn't know the difference
between a child and adult.
And so I didn't understand
what was being done to me was wrong.
But as I grew older, I
understood it was wrong,
because I was a kid.
So to a child, no, I
don't understand that,
because I didn't understand
what was done to me,
and I wouldn't want another child
to have to go through that.
- [Mark] Good for you.
Yeah, you've been through a lot.
That kinda derails the
way your brain works
after that, doesn't it?
- Yes, it does.
I mean, I think I'm a failure,
and still a fairly intelligent person.
And like I said, I have tried
to reach and get out of here.
I believe every situation
I've been put in,
in life coming up, and
the people I've met,
was something that
I needed to learn to
continue to cope with life.
The good and the bad
has all been just things
to help me become a better person.
And like I said, I still want the best.
I still want to believe that someday
this will all be behind me,
and I can achieve something out of life,
and maybe help others that
went through the same thing.
I don't know.
Maybe I can talk about it one day.
There's other people
just like me out there
who needs some type of a guidance.
And I can tell them what it took
for me to just live this long,
and continue to believe that
life is gonna be okay for me.
- [Mark] Yeah, you deserve everything
that life has to offer.
- Yes, exactly.
- [Mark] I hope it comes your way.
- [Mark] All right,
J.J., thank you so much
for sharing your story.
- And thank you,
- [Mark] I wish you the best of luck.
- Thank you.
- You know, I haven't told
nobody that whole story before.
- [Mark] Really?
- Never told anybody that whole story
- [Mark] How's it feel?
- Well, it feels okay,
and then I feel like, 'cause
what is my family gonna say?
Because I've never told 'em
- [Mark] Well, I mean, (chuckles)
they really can't condemn
you for talking about.
They're the ones that should be.
- Well maybe they need to know.
- [Mark] I would say so, yeah.
- Maybe they need to
know, but I have never sat
and told anyone that whole story before,
and maybe all this happened
because it's time that
somebody needs to know.
Wow, that's why he's going through that.
That's why he got.
- [Mark] I mean, as an
outsider who just met you,
looking at you,
you're handsome, you're intelligent.
You speak beautifully.
You present yourself really well,
and yet I'm sure you have
this very negative view
of yourself, because of that childhood.
- Yeah, I do.
- [Mark] Not just the molestation,
but everything else, the
way you were treated.
- Yeah,
- [Mark] And you deserve any of that.
You deserve to live the best
life you can possibly dream of.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And yet you're here on Skid Row
living like a...
- Yeah, I don't know what to say.
- [Mark] And I'm like, it does.
When you came walking up, I'm like,
well he's not. (chuckles)
- Yeah.
- [Mark] He's not somebody
I want to interview,
but your story is incredible.
- Thank you.
- [Mark] You don't deserve a bit of it.
Thank you man.
- [Mark] No one does.
- I appreciate you.